une production du studio sf
bio venus s'offrir le présent le parquet
semi le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut nous inviter date saint-quentin
avec moi double en caisse me vient de
lancer plusieurs nouveaux produits dans
les derniers dernières semaines derniers
mois ils ont lancé un caisse pour vos
impôts nouveaux airpod pro que vous
pouvez personnaliser à votre image dont
l'ancienne batterie portative mois chez
que je m'en sers pas ce que mon cell la
batterie se décharge et puis ils vivent
vraiment rapidement et sinon lion d or
du chef pour vos ordinateurs portatifs
donc encore une fois il prendre à votre
image et personnaliser votre expérience
pour tout produit chez inutilisés la sf
15 nice pour 15 % de rabais d'hommes
s'est tenu cette semaine c'est un grand
plaisir de recevoir marjolaine caduque
et nutritionniste très active sur
instagram sont aux 35 ans et les pieds
dans les plats les la suivre elle
vraiment super intéressante et
instructive super impertinente et ont
valu à recevoir en fait parce qu'elle en
fait on faisait écrit elle pour réagir
sur des propos contenu sur le podcast
piqué qu'il avait un peu titillé dont
complet des pluies fait ça par l'état
des caisses en insuline une discussion
super intéressante je pars niveau c est
les antilles est ainsi en fait
culture des diètes en fait tant que la
maturité de la minceur perdu peu à tout
prix
donc
évidemment on est d'accord avec ce qui
évidemment de plusieurs principes
de l'alimentation l apprendre
l'alimentation intuitive qui n'est ce
pas une façon super intéressante de voir
l'alimentation de voir notre relation
avec la nourriture était d'abord une
relation plus saine je pense que on y
beaucoup à
souffrir un peu d'une relation petit peu
difficile un peu tordue avec la
nourriture d'ailleurs ce que une
discussion autour de la nourriture
autres la culpabilité qu en tout cas
trop de ceux à taux fixe autour du court
un peu parce qu'on en a parlé quand même
dans le podcast c'est que ça peut
déranger
peut-être sauté sur votre caste ou peut
être juste en est conscient et on va
aborder c'est terminé ainsi ces thèmes
là mais sinon je vous assure que les
discussions étaient vraiment super
intéressante super nuancer ce faire
pertinent je crois qui j'espère que and
his way tout à fait fait qu'avant
d'aller écouter cette conversation on va
les remercier nos commanditaires hier le
podcast aujourd'hui est présenté par
auch lag qui est commanditaire officiel
du studio qui nous fournit un produit
leurs produits tout aussi délicieux ira
fini les uns que les autres j'en ai
plusieurs ici j'ai lors jean jé des
ceintures noires et puis que j'ai dit
que j'allais sortir cet été c'était là
ça a été la la la la cuisine s la
révélation en révélation c'est dur mais
moins dix ans a préféré c'est vraiment
hors de tout doute les poches lag les et
les est consommé à peu près
à chaque va envoyer aussi elle a
resserré la nano blonde qui est leur
série nano dans le fossé des bières
moins alcoolisés mois la nano blonde
sait vraiment je l' ai vraiment beaucoup
parce que j'adore probable hier mais des
fois c'est quand tu vois la bière défaut
de s'ouvrir un peu chaude à et puis la
meinau blonde permirent de beaux la
bière rester chez eux pendant les
podcasts surtout qui hachent lac vient
de recevoir pour sa série régulière une
vérification d'aliments du québec ça
veut dire que 85 % ou plus de leurs
ingrédients sont d'ici du québec ça ça
inclut aussi la transformation et
l'emballage préparés au québec leur
série régulière c'est la blonde n'a
blanche larousse la new england à épier
la stat blanche
honnêtement c'est magnifique puis nous
on est très fiers de collaborer avec eux
parce que c'est les produits qu'on a
donc on a dû nancy pour la dynamique
qu'on adore fait merci beaucoup à slash
puis aller tester leur cause
le barca d'aujourd'hui est présenté par
robert deux lieux qui font de la
nourriture pour chien pour les produits
innovants hypoallergénique éco
responsable à base de protéine
alternative c'est quoi cet hôtel
alternative y en a pleins ça peut être
des gâteries à base de grillades et
autres idées gagnent à base d'algues de
la gaspésie s'est fait au québec par des
grandes ici donc ministre y suit une
compagnie locale on encourage l'économie
locale c'est bien important puis il
annoncera base d'insectes à base de
poisson durable en ou des poissons
vivants ouais les poissons durables des
carpes asiatiques qui détruisent les
fonds marins qui doivent être pêchées
fait que warner et le travail des
pêcheurs d'amérique du nord pour faire
ça de façon durable je reçois
honnêtement j'ai des amis qui ont des
tombes et des chiens les animaux de la
scanie puis les chiens pour les
non-initiés dit c'est dingue la crèche
idiotie genre à aimer la race canine des
chiens pour les non dits
[Rires]
puis il me recommande où ils me
remercient en fait du code promo de
wilder mieux parce que leur chien trip
puis il ya même un groupe d'amis qui ont
des chiens un chien qui peut pas manger
toutes les la nourriture à goz
allergique peut manger les la nourriture
dewar de rire fait honnêtement c'est
innovant c'est durable c'est bon pour
l'environnement la santé pour le 6
décembre et pour les chiens votre chien
va adorer ça puis on a un code promo
pour vous qui est le sf 20 sur leur site
web mon chien sauve le monde point ci a
fait qu'aller voir ceux utilisés en cas
de problème comme s'il faut savoir que
c'est nous qui vous envoie et votre
chien va se régaler merci beaucoup voire
de reyrieux merci à vous de nous
encourager ouf
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah
oui j'allais merci d'être là à l'eau
ça va super j'avais vraiment qu'on te
reçoivent le cas quand tu as écrit mais
tu nous as écrit en fait surtout au
podcast avec jean philippe wauthier on
en reparlera mais mais après ce que j'ai
fait à quelle belle opportunité parce
que moi je sais on a un ami commun
qu'ils avaient ébauché qu'est ce tu es
sûre sur le web je trouve ça super cool
super pertinent fait que je me suis dit
ça faisait longtemps qu'on leur parle et
nutrition encore quelques bonnes
occasions
jamais trop arrêtez soit
on la parle pas trop mais
pas un truc super intéressant alors si
deux fois bernard
3e faute d'avoir nouvelle vers ces
nouvelles perspectives l'échec vous
rejoignez quand même sur plusieurs trucs
le 8 août a fait la différence c'est que
je suis clinicienne donc moi je
rencontre des gens et en one man one
vraiment été des rencontres et
individuelle prend pas à berne en
tchéquie plus dans les médias
qui fait un super bon travail de
vulgarisation mais tichy comme un peu
plus sur le terrain pas que ça fera une
différence que jamais leur enclos du
monde du travail mais certainement que
cette double dans le fond tu sais si tu
es tu dans un hôpital ou
au privé puis les gens viennent ici au
privé fait que les gens prennent rendez
vous et les consulter à saint-didier
comme très voir un psy
exactement souvent j'imagine que c'est
pour essayer de voir dans leur quotidien
quelles sont les habitudes sont saines
lesquels ne sont pas ou ce que les gens
qui viennent te voir en plus quelque
chose en tête un objectif
ce soit lié on voir parle évidemment
mais à la perte de poids ou que ce soit
lié à un hic c'est qu'à force et quoi
pourquoi les gens viendront c'est assez
varié c'est sûr que sur les réseaux
sociaux mon approche est quand même des
jeux la fiche beaucoup avec les gens qui
m'écrivent savent que je n'ai approché
d'alimentation petite fille mais je
rencontre des gens qui ont du diabète
qui ont un foie gras qui veulent perdre
du poids pile qui est à 7 de voir
comment je peux en allemand à saint tite
river perdre du poids c'est ce pari
vraiment
des gens qui ont des troubles mentaux
oui troubles alimentaires ou si c'est
vraiment ce que je fais le plus le 10
mai ouais tu parles de ton approche sur
les réseaux sociaux
comment est ce parce que c'est quand
même un courant qui restent à
l'alimentation est utile puis le
l'approchent que toi tu avais qu avec la
nutrition du mois sur les plateaux de
reçus comment comment est ce que
on peut catégoriser cette approche ne
mettons pas ce que bernard laval est
une tendance qu'on voit vraiment
apparaître de plus en plus dans les
petites trois quatre dernières années
avant sur mes joues ton alimentation est
utile c'était vraiment pas un mot que
j'avais entendu avant sur le comment
est-ce qu'on caractérise sur pièce que
ça est-ce que ça sort de l'école ou
est-ce que
c'est comme une espèce de nouvelles
orientations de la nutrition or des
bancs d'école en fait la prochaine été
inventé en 1995 allez quand même évolué
mais c'est pas nouveau le savate gang
des années 90 s et d'une pianiste aux
états unis qu'ils ont comme inventer son
voeu mais encore là comme une salle
beaucoup évolué au début c'était
vraiment pas ce que c'est aujourd'hui
mais effectivement c'est pas une
approche qui énormément saignée dans le
bac c'est le bac veut nous former avec
une personnalité qui va être la plus
polyvalente possédant un bac cutoff
louis ces trois ans et demi c'est très
exigeant mais c'est susciter le bus et
comptables polyvalent mais après c'est à
nous à liszt forme et machet de la
clinique en tout une dizaine y en a qui
travaillent dans les hôpitaux mais
j'étais fort mais aussi pour travailler
dans un hôpital puis voir plein de deux
coeurs en hôpital fait justement c'est
une approche qui est très spécifique
qu'il faut aller se former après pied
aller chercher je demande l'appui des
ressources puis le la proche de vente
avant tout une approche pense qui dit à
10,8 me puis en quoi le mentation et
yves c'est pas une
en fait une diète souvent ça veux te
dire de manger selon des signaux
extérieurs à toi elle mange parce que
c'est l'heure de manger ou manger une
portion s'activent visuel qui fait la
bonne chose l'allemand tu as un petit
thé sadies ben reconnecte simple en fait
avec ton corps avec des signaux interne
du fait que c'est vraiment l'eau c'est
plutôt différent
puis mettons qu'on la
croie décrivez ou qu'on le
sait la zone asie ça serait quoi mettons
les grands principes outils en groupe b
lieu des 10 grands principes de
l'alimentation et du 10
10 avec le mot
nettement les 10 geckos n'est pas par
coeur parce que dans ma pratique je peux
comme acquis aujourd'hui on travaille le
principe de tout un briquet un peu 1
dans l'autre c'est de bouger par plaisir
de respecter son corps respecté ces
signaux corporels est de rejeter la
culture des diètes aussi c'est un
principe de l'alimentation du tiw mais
en fait une réponse à la culture des
tests une façon de manger qui répond un
peu réac qui essaient de contrebalancer
les effets la culture du siècle est ce
que je me trompe si je dis que
ce nouveau courant de connaissances en
nutrition s'intéresse plus mais
s'intéresse autant à la santé physique
qui a la santé social à la santé je sais
que le gic moutons oui c'est quand même
un des enjeux importants j'imagine parce
que si je prends juste un de ces
facteurs le
individuellement
la réponse doit pas être la même que
c'était se déconsidérer les troupes
souvent je demande c'est mes clients
vont me parler de santé mais on associer
beaucoup je m'inclus dans ce la santé
égal 1 apparence physique tc très 6ec la
santé mais même loup m s dans sa
définition à une approche des social
piment talent fax et d'essayer de faire
quelque chose de plus complète on voit
lundi dans sa globalité peu juste belle
et son poids ou son corps pour la santé
mais est-ce que c'est quand même
important
en fait je pose la question mais mon
jeu j'ai pas de jeu pas la géologie pas
la réponse là mais j'ai plein de
questionnements par rapport à ce parce
que on rejoue retourner un peu plus loin
tantôt le mais
c'est pas
ça c'est important aussi d'être capable
de connaître les résultats de chaque
décision sur chacun des facteurs de la
santé m'étonne c'est au sens où si si tu
veux maintenant aller prendre un verre
le soir le pis que pour ton ta santé
social met on est quand même important
de savoir son impact à cette décision-là
sur la santé physique au site chaque
fois capable de décortiquer oui aussi le
ti au même titre que met-on si tu as
besoin pour ta santé psychologique de
je peux descendre un sac de chips on
écoute un squeeze games ce que ça arrive
à tout le monde c'est nécessaire mais
faut quand même que tu sois conscient de
l'impact sur la santé physique puis je
trouve que je trouve que mettons dans
tout le discours autour de
l'alimentation et du tir puis de pipi
des différences domaine de santé je
trouve que je trouve que c'est ça
devient un peu mélangés j'ai
l'impression puis moi c'est là que j'ai
comme un peu de jeu de la misère à me
positionner dans tout ça parce que je me
dis je comprends tout ce qu'on dit
tantôt maintenant sur l'alimentation du
sud comprend absolument tu puisses a
fait tout le stout le bon sens du monde
le titre les justes les principes
d'éthique et énumérer mais après je me
dis admettons qu'on
qu'on n'est pas capable de te des
mélanges et tout seul puis qu'on
commence à penser quelque chose qui est
finalement une action qu'on fait pour
notre santé psychologique finalement
c'est juste un être plus alors qu'il ya
quand même des les enjeux négatif de
l'autre bord le team parce que tu fais
comment qu'on se positionne là dedans
comment qu'on fait pour un peu de
malades mais je comprends tu mets ma
question oui mais ce que j'entends ces
petites emplettes la santé physique et
peut-être mis de côté en alimentation
public la santé physique mais aussi dans
d'autres contextes et la santé social
aussi les pieds parce que quand
justement si pour reprendre l'exemple de
je mangeais ça que tu pourrais plus cool
game mis au site est seul chez vous a
écouté ce coup de game ma place de le
socialiser puis de renvoi des amis
d'entretenir des relations qui serait
meaningful dans deux langues mais là
parce que tu veux parce que tu as besoin
d'écouter ce coup de game à ce moment là
mais faut que tu saches tout change
quand même que cette décision lors d'un
impact sur les autres penchant de la
santé mais inversement ce triste sort si
tu le fais bien manger c'est manger de
bons éléments tout le temps fait que je
te sors plus non plus saisi toutes ses
facultés comme un équilibre à trouver
qui qui disent il quand même mais c'est
vraiment du style qui la façon que je
les approches puis c'est parce que des
fois qu'ils manquent qu'on comprend
postic les connaissances en nutrition
qu'on est de savoir que des fruits des
légumes part contributive des choses
comme ça on les cartes peu dans
l'allemande à mendive j'invite justement
mes clients à trouver je te demande est
etc les bleus de baic est ce que j'ai
besoin en ce moment puis comment est-ce
que ça peut être satisfaisante un petit
les clips de ben moi le matin avant de
travailler j'ai besoin d'un déjeuner qui
soutenait gib un beau vouloir manger je
ne sais pas un jour lui pour déjeuner ça
veut peut me soutenir même si j'en ai
envie c'est pas l'allemand qui me font
en ce moment accent plus c'est la façon
qu'on veut chercher les clips les
connaissances le rationnel et quand même
le dans l'alimentation est un peu ce qui
fait le pont entre les trois points je
vous dise le groupe fût-il le mot
intuitif donne une idée de ce que c'est
que c est en réalité c'est pas
exactement c'est dans ce sens que je
vais souvent le
son le définit paul et j'entends
d'alimentation intuitive puis c'est
quand je peux manger ce que je veux
quand je veux que j'ai envie de manger
hypothécaires en quantité n'importe
lequel et puis c'est plus complexe mais
j'ai l'impression que mon nom on
comprend justement l'alimentation
impulsive mais c'est pas un peu plus les
bleus l'alimentation du christ est quand
même d'une certaine façon réfléchie pipe
plus qu'on l'intègre plus que saviez
naturel si je me pose plus la question
le matin savoir est ce que j'ai besoin
d'un déjeuner sous temps je sais j'ai
besoin d'un déjeuner sous clans qu'après
ce qu'est ce que j'ai dans l'oeuf devant
moi qui va me permettre d'être
satisfaisant y soutenant mais c'est une
réflexion que j'ai tout le temps toutes
les connaissances nécessaires pour
savoir qu'est ce qui soutenait qui sait
quoi tu y mange équilibré et il domine
nutriments c'est quand même même si je
calcule pour chaque portion cette
affaire
j'imagine que globalement suis pense
quand même hacker faut que je mange une
variété de d'aliments qui font rager les
matins sont complètement mais maintenant
non ben non j'étais je dis je m'écoute
comme j j'ai fait que c'est une
expérience très personnelle mais je vais
écouter mais je vais site conçu de
prendre en compte aussi c'est quoi mes
besoins mettez je laisse exige pendant
une fin de semaine je fais juste manger
et de l'arthur la restauration
naturellement je sais qu'en début de
semaine j horde de manger des fruits et
des légumes je me lève aux pcistes aussi
qu'elle rend plus agréable
l'astuce est quand même titre s'est
qualifiée légumes ces pilules je suis
peut-être falloir prendre que ces
meilleurs la santé non mais c'est
naturel c'est je suis pas souvent
l'exemple que je ne sais je sais que ça
ait déjà fait des voyages scolaires
c'est que quand on va à new york quatre
jours puis on fait juste manger du resto
pendant quatre jours on vient la maison
qui on ne le goûter de quelque chose de
croquant de frais mais pour moi c'est ce
qu'ils croient qu'un free la fraîcheur
est associé à des fruits et légumes mais
ça se peut que quelqu'un d'autre ce sera
autre chose métier c'est coloré c'est
beau enfin on arrête de manger du brun
mais si ça se fait plus naturellement
c'est pas que je me dis j'ai mangé en
fin de semaine et des aliments le fauche
compense ce saffré comme justement une
forme de compensation
j'ai mangé quelque chose de mauvais on
dit mais j'ai mangé quelque chose de bon
en guinée mais ça c'est très
naturellement quand t'écoutes encore le
sas et moi cette expérience le jeu
gilles contraire au sens où quand
mettons je tombe sur un patin ou est-ce
que je suis sa route le je mange la de
la scrap
je tombe comme un
cercle de joie manger encore l'âge de la
scrap ta vie j'ai envie d'en manger
encore j'ai envie de me faire encore
livres et cd fois je passe sur des mots
ce qui sonne pratiquement tout le temps
chez nous mais cache cache j'ouvre la
porte à ce sombre de dans le métier puis
je tombe dedans jusqu'à temps qu'il a
menée c'est pas que j'ai envie de manger
plus sainement c'est que je me dis le
faut joe wright c'est parce que pour on
y reviendra mais pour la santé physique
je me dis ça n'a pas de bon sens parce
que c'est vraiment si c'est des aliments
qui ne nourrissent pas du tout mais qui
font jusqu'à même alimenter mon désir de
plus de friture bâton puis ma santé
financières aussi est ce que je dis là
n'est pas que je cultive fait qu'il ya
tout le temps mais ce réflexe classe si
j'avais pas si on m'avait dit toute ma
vie mais tant que le mec d'eau était bon
pour ma santé probablement que je serais
capable de
manger du riz w non-stop
pendant que ce serait long avant que mon
coeur je me tirerais sûrement
éventuellement est vraiment que j'aurais
déjà fait assez de dommages moraux corps
ouais je pense que oui qui je pense que
oui mais parce qu'un petit déjà je dois
chi
[Musique]
chi et c'est cela la le régime de vie le
thé de manger beaucoup beaucoup de
restaurants boîtes groupe tpiy
c'est sans jugement mairie et des
chantiers stx poteau mais non plus de
moi j'ai beaucoup trop et légumes mais
souvent mal j'irai je serais curieuse de
savoir pourquoi cette personne ne
s'émeut ton l'on ne donnait l'exemple de
restauration à peine moins d'en manger
autant c'est quel besoin ça vient
combler ou qu'est ce que tu fais qui est
ton de vars est ce que c'est vraiment
par plaisir parce qu'encore le dans
l'alimentation qui suivent il ya un
certain qu'il ya une certaine
dégustation des aliments pris un certain
plaisir qu'alimentation vient nous
donner jeudi un maillon le jeune en
super size me aussi le gris et un vernis
de manger qui m'entoure je me dis la
personne que son régime alimentaire
n'est que ce mais est-ce qu'il prend
vraiment le temps de le manger aussi
juste ronde une habitude et qu'est ce
qui fait que sur les aliments le cse la
facilité peu compétences culinaires et
c'est pas d'intérêt non plus vers la
cuisine mais ça peut expliquer son choix
mais c'est pas par plaisir c'est une
époque comme je vais manger du mec doit
tous les jours c'est comme c'est facile
c'est peu cher puissamment sommes combat
je vais prendre ce prix qui est ce que
tu penses que le facteur plaisir est un
facteur qu'on sous-estimé
dans l'alimentation en général parce que
moi je crois que si les gens mais ton
je découvrais le plaisir de manger du
chauffeur le funky puis de pagis manger
pour ce que ça procure mais manger pour
l'action de le faire peut-être que
peut-être que s'il y aurait moins seul
mais
l'aspect satisfaction si j'ai beaucoup
mes clients qu'ils savent pas de
questions envie de manger c'est vraiment
difficile pour eux de dire j'ai envie de
déjeuner mais gens ils savent pas ce
qu'ils veulent manger c'est faux je
refasse un homme décisionnel pour des
vrais gens non décisionnel pour les
aider à prendre une décision ça les aide
vraiment des seins qui finalement je
mange quelque chose de satisfaisant je
pense d'un autre appel mais ça c'est
quelque chose d'immonde beaucoup les
jeux reculé en pop up maintenant mon ma
relation avec la nutrition mais j'ai
fait du sport vraiment pendant longtemps
avec le rouge et or puis j'avais des
nutritionnistes qui me suivait c'est
pour mon alimentation puis - les
aliments ça l'a toujours été
vraiment
cartésien pu déchiffrer dans le sens où
j'ai calculé qu'on c'était quoi mon
besoins en calories pour l'effort que je
donnais versus qu'est-ce qui vaut le
chic c'est extrêmement peu en mode de
dire ça mais qu'est-ce qui va contrôler
mon poids parce que dans le sport à ce
niveau là c'est quand même un facteur on
peut pas si on peut pas dire le
contraire fait klaus était tout le temps
la balance en kiosque jusqu'au bout je
mange sans dépasser la limite mais ton
puis les aliments mis un à côté de
l'autre il y en a il y avait toujours
une option qui était supérieur à l'autre
mais c'est sûr
sur papier dans le fonds etic une des
affaires que moi j'ai de la misère à
comprendre dans tout ça c'est le fameux
il n'y a pas d'aliment meilleur qu'un
autre
parce que factuellement ce pauvre et
voilà une valeur nutritive l'oeuf
actuellement c'est pas vrai pour la
santé du corps c'est factuellement pas
vrai pour la santé comme on parle tantôt
physique pour la santé mentale sociale
c'est vrai le tuer mais pour la santé
physique c'est pas vrai fait comment est
ce que on
navigue ces eaux là tant qu'on parle
justement tu sais pas ce qu'on n'en
parlait jamais avec jean philippe
wauthier du clip qui avaient circulé le
2 le bernois la vallée à bonsoir bonsoir
qui disent essentiellement qui a pas
d'aliment meilleurs que d'autres
mais c'est là que j'ai de la misère à
embarquer parce que c'est pas vrai tu
fais comment est-ce que
dans l'optique de dire l'alimentation
étudiants il faut que les gens prennent
des choix intuitif mais éduquer mes
collègues du côté de l'éducation ont dit
quelque chose qui est factuellement faux
comment conjuguer avec ceux du combat tu
manges et c'est là que j'ai de la misère
parce que parce que c'est volts et moi
c'est de là que ça vient c'est là que ça
vient montmartre relation
qu'alimentation g j'ai été extrêmement
chanceux de jamais de développer de
problèmes liés à ce chèque dans le sport
de haut niveau sur ce tract ou une autre
un autre dossier complet des problèmes
d'alimentation
c'est un fléau le pour potentiellement
plus à cause de la culture que mettons
du désir de performance mais
effectivement condamné sûr parce que
c'est là que jean marc pons dray c'est
l'objet de la mesure mais en fait oui on
peut c'est catégorie vraiment et de
monsieur dit d'un point de vue
nutritionnel
si on pourrait les catégories et ma
tante et vin jaune rouge au niveau des
aliments mais après si c'est un facteur
précis de l'allemand ben c'est l'aspect
nutritionnel imprécis refait l'exercice
qui ont pas justement de la facilité de
l'aliment est pris par être mangés belle
alice très différente au niveau vert
jaune rouge ses impressions de vie le
coût est les préférences kg on peut
faire c'est un exercice que cheikh me
criant long nez plein catégorique en
fait qu'on descend puis se rendre compte
finalement qu'une allemands qui étaient
dans le rouge peut être en tout dans son
vin après ce saut dans le vert selon
comment y catégoriser et c'est là au
monde il ya tellement de catégorie les
allemands vont tellement tout le temps
changer de catégorie qu est-ce qu on
peut juste les enlever au final ces
catégories on peut rester conscient qui
est comme une valeur nutritive qui peut
être supérieure dung a demandé ensuite
un autre mais c'est que ça devrait pas
mener mon choix selon mon besoin que
j'ai besoin de quelque chose de rapide
et leur faut que je veux absolument me
faire quelque chose de ma maison maman
je commence à extrait système
culpabiliser parce que je le mange peu
le produit maison je mange les produits
préparés c'est ce qui plutôt
problématique du château je comprends ce
que tu veux dire et puis ça fait tout le
sens du monde parce qu'effectivement qu
moi je suis le premier de ces moi je
prends mon exemple mais je te remettra
un training au début du paka ce sens
elle est là parce que parce que moi j'ai
eu peur j'ai pas de problème m avec ces
outils puis mettons quand je suis chez
nous puis que j'ai
le choix entre par exemple
je suis mangé des des carottes en
crudités rapide hubei non le soma par
exemple mais tant que j'ai le choix on
dit au québec la place de me faire un
super avec band et légumes
puis je sais que le spag il y aura pas
les mêmes nutriments mettons que je sais
que pour les valeurs nutritives
c'est moins bon que si je me faisais un
genre de sauter plus remplis de légumes
le bourg et de près nutriments sauf que
je prends la décision hamza mais leur
joie je vais prendre sur l'échelle
mettons comprend l'échelle vert jaune
rouge va prendre l'échelle va rejoindre
rouge de la rapidité de la facilité sauf
que je suis conscient que je prends
cette décision l'autriche conscient que
la décision je la prends selon la valeur
de l'aliment mai encore le guide sont
quand même catégorie zehti dans ma tête
même si jules je le mets pas dans l'est
dans des bains et décide de partir
compte sur ce terreau paul comme je suis
quand même conscient qu'il ya qu'il y
avait un meilleur choix pour ma santé
physique dont mais c'est l'autre est
dans ton corps tu vas pas prioriser la
santé physique c'est peut-être au
détriment d'autres choses mais c'est
vers la santé physique c'est important
mais est-ce qu'on peut justement l'art
décembre qu'il yad'autres tout à fait la
santé qui seront importants qui sait
aussi l'aspect que un repas qui est peu
de légumes je sais que la fing pendant
mais non non c'est pour ça que j'en
mange copieusement plus que le contrat
est soumis on repasse à légumes c'est
pas grave je te mets où tous les repas
sans légumes long le problème mais
encore les matins frais par curiosité
pourquoi quelqu'un mange jamais de
légumes est-ce que c'est comme comment
les transformer en corrèze qui a des
compétences culinaires est-ce que c'est
accessible et des endroits à montréal où
c'est vraiment pas que tu essaies bout
c'est hors de prix l'ifri les légumes
taxer l'eau souvent votre
responsabiliser la personne ne tente
mais moyon dont la pointe droite mangent
pas de légumes qui pourtant que c'est
que c'est bon mais on est ce qu'on peut
voir aussi l'environnement dans laquelle
à personne et qui comprend aussi
pourquoi est ce qui est ange qui mange
le tc poèmes souvent ça va pas être
qu'elle le ceppol des légumes qui
défrise intéressante on le sait le
milieu raisons qui mènent aux
métiers mois mettant
étant jeune j'aimais pas les légumes qui
permet par asgatech mort et légumes tout
le temps et pourtant
c'est ici c'est objectivement bon pour
toi le manger beaucoup de légumes et on
le sait mais intuitivement mon mon corps
puis mon goût d'enfants voulait rien
savoir des limites et fait quand même
quelque chose de curieux que tu ne veux
pas quelque chose qui pigent méga rocher
sacré menacé le tenait mais pis le est
adulte qui éviterait mes parents mais a
répété que c'est important que je mange
un légume gens mangent aujourd'hui des
légumes mais si pour encore à ce jour ce
pas la chose préféré dans le monde ne
tue la manche parce que je sais que
c'est important puis juste et j'apprends
aussi à les apprêter de meneur qui plus
intéressante que c'est meilleur
métier si j'écoutais juste mon goût
personnel pour moi prenons jamais un
truc mais c'est le comme je disais
tantôt steeple alimentation impulsive
calandre est ici il ya quand même des
connaissances tactiques tes parents tu
invites à manger des légumes obligé le
soft un autre stage invite à manger des
légumes allaient découvrir et/ou ou que
toi tu dises bien quand je rigole je me
sens plus soutenu ça me fait du bien
après le repas je me sens mieux que si
j'avais juste mangé un autre peu mais ça
reste l'alimentation et souris c'est
correct d'avoir cette réflexion le faut
juste pas que ça devienne obsédant
culpabilisant est ce la ligne mais c'est
intéressant 90e après aussi dit il comme
important qu'on stérile sur la gestion
le comment je me sentirai après mon
repos noyés parce que souvent justement
tu mets ton
l'envi de manger du mcdo a pas très
forte mais je suis quand même le
souvenir qu'à chaque fois je mangeais
mètres d'eau puis je parle un peu de
culpabilité
physiquement je me sens pas bien je me
sens payés la forme bien été c'est comme
juste
papa etc qui s'appuie sur une affaire de
des standards de beauté quoi que ce soit
et juste une belle soeur physiquement
pas bien
puis un versement des fois des choses -
j'ai pas le excitante radi et antiques
arrive en tournée était le seul étranger
au poulet avec la salade un qui arrête à
l'épicerie
précis oui ça fait part que l'équation
exactement c'est pas une [ __ ] c'est
comme si une bombe implicite c'est
réfléchi je pourrai manger ma tante est
épais acheter un athlète préféré le
matin j'ai envie de manger une poutine
je la mange ouais mais c'est parce que
s'il faut j'aime m'entraîner a priori
pas bien payé est un moment qui est
approprié pour la manger puis sans que
ça devienne encore une fois une règle je
dois absolument la manger le soir
absolument la manger la fin de semaine
c'est quand même de réfléchir à hakim
est ce parce qu'après il faut que je
continue ma journée leur est ce que
l'allemand ou le choix que de jeunes de
femmes me permet de vivre des
expériences que je vive ou aux
contrastes avons comme m'affecter mais
j'ai l'impression quand même au delà
jusqu'à
28 cents par rapport à près avoir mangé
excuserez qu'aliment moi mettons ce qui
est ce qui guide ma décision de ne pas
manger une poutine parce que je vais
m'entraîner après c'est aussi
une base de connaissances sur qu'est ce
que tu as besoin à gérer avant tellement
idée de ce fait que c est important d
avoir quand même assez bas de connaître
ses bases de connaissances le sur
les valeurs nutritives d'un élément qui
fait que c'est important d'être de
savoir quel genre de chose il faut que
tu consommes dans quel contexte avant de
pouvoir adhérer vraiment une
alimentation et nutrition
mais c'est quelque chose qui peut être
travaillée telle alimentation duty ou
l'espace exclu peu de dire ben justement
avant l'entraînement ou une source de
glucides moutons mais de dire voici des
sources de glucides qu'est-ce-qui
satisfaisant pourquoi dans ce facto
l'aspect satisfaction plaisir pitot
l'aspect ben je tenterai nourrir mon
corps pour le besoin qui vous allez
faire ac c'est quelque chose qui
s'excluent peu la demande atteint du tiw
et le sport
puis techniquement la poutine à quoi
pourrait faire le travail
je pense que un gros c les chocs on est
d'accord sur tout et pratiquement à tous
nos métiers en gros
c'est comme si les réserves le malaise
des fautes et qu'on convoite dans
certains propos c'est comme qu'on n'ose
plus dire qu'ils ont peut-être
peut-être que le cockpit mcdo c'est pas
bon pour toi tu y mets ton physiquement
entier puis sans jeter du surpuissant
jugement en puissance je comprends que
protecteur mais je pense que c'est très
important d'être au courant comme c'est
quand même quand on est au courant que
dormir huit heures par nuit en moyenne
ces bons depuis que l'erreur du port ce
faire l'espace est bon depuis que fumer
c'est peut-être pas bon pour tous at il
dit tu vois les grandes lignes la pythie
après ce jeudi ce fumiste pas bon pour
toi après ce jeu juge pas les gens qui
le font les genres je comprends que
prenant plein de facteurs qui est
organique de compte mais actuellement à
bout de ligne
ouais c'est juste qu'au niveau
alimentaire si tu vas mené de manière
très culpabilisant donc moins de
beaucoup les gens soient ce problème
c'est ce qui est très problématique
aussi ping mon approche aussi que j'ai
dit que je trouvais important qu'on
amène cette nuance le sais que mon
objectif c'est de donner les
informations à mon client le client
prend sa décision il ya eu le droit
d'aller manger du manque d'eau stagnante
au final lui comme des gens fument staff
que c'est oui pas nécessairement idéal
je n'ai pas qu'on le savait même pas où
me sens qu'elle fût mais il ne reconnaît
pas que comme tout le monde le faisait
un film en compagnie de ta beauté comme
il était bon pour toi c'est bon pour toi
vas-y vas-y plein tour de france avec
une top bush mais n'en n'ont cessé de
démontrer que c'est prouvé que ça c'est
ça s'arrête elle telle conséquence la
santé ce qui est important d'avoir
l'information juste et oui ça fait mal
pour ça oui je vais exposer cette cet
argumentaire le puits après six touches
ou à la personne mais encore le fou peut
que se faire culpabiliser en manger du
mcdo encore une fois quelqu'un qui les
fait de manière consciente va pas manger
du mcdo à tous les jours nous paraît
vraiment désagréable
c'est ceux d'en face et la question de
la culpabilité la culpabilisation
laitiers jetons peu ce qu'ils écrivaient
aussitôt podcast avec jacques legros
qu'il étudiait qu'on parlait beaucoup de
culpabilisation
sais quoi parce que c'est une écrit
après spa kaeslin et des propos de
déranger la faune le tc quoi gros qui
quitta pas aimer ou équipes quittaient
peu
juste a dit m ben c'est juste le propos
en général tout ce que j'entends souvent
plus je pense parler d'activité physique
quand même beaucoup dans le pré casse de
voir l'activité visée comme une façon de
se déculpabiliser par rapport à
l'alimentation
donc si je vais m'entraîner bella je
peux me permettre un aliment
baisser l'activité physique devrait être
fait dans le plaisir et non pas pour me
déculpabiliser mangin bay resort pour me
permettre de manger un aliment
particulier non je comprends mais je
suppose que nous mettons mois pour
personnellement celle inverse ce que ça
fait qu'achever l'activité physique je
feuillette j'aime prendre une bonne
décision mais ton pour ma santé pour moi
je me sens bien j'ai le goût de rester à
statoil puis de bien manger souvent qu
en cuir
les périodes que je vois moins bien
manger puis béton jeunes tels que je
suis plus stressé et peut-être que je
travaille plus pour exploiter une raison
je mange moins bien qui fait moins de
sport souvent ça va ensemble moi
personnellement c'est rock et je veux
courir mais du bon avec le ch plus
manger de la junk food j'aime les gens
restent que tu t'entraînes pour manger
où tu manges pour t'entraîner le thé
gens je l'entends souvent c'était
beaucoup de gens c'est comme je
m'entraîne pour manger dame enlève une
culpabilité de temps mais je me suis
entraîné je peux me permettre ce
je pense moi si c'est un propos je me
disais justement ça ramène à culpabilité
devais je m'entraîne peuvent que je peux
pas me permettre certains allemands puis
si je m'entraîne je peux me permettre
je comprends peut-être que c'est moi qui
ai eu
en fait à la lumière de touche pour
possiblement que j'ai un mauvais réflexe
puis que faudrait que je le modifie mais
que moi c'est comme ça que j'ai toujours
fonctionné puis
la culpabilité dont le skim mike
beaucoup à ce jour par rapport à
l'alimentation mais dans ma vie en
général la culpabilité de moi voir
moi-même n'avoir pas fait ce que je
m'attendais à moi même de faire le team
est temps pour l'entraînement le tri
l'entraînement la fin de l'équation
complet le mettons m'entraîner pour le
marathon le que j'ai fait au début du
mois à fin du parcours au complet c'est
un est positif le énorme sauf que pour
me rendre à ce mets ton je suis sûr
qu'il ya plein de de comportement quand
même problématique dans ma vie desquels
je suis conscient mais ton comme là on
en parle le timon beaucoup de fois où
est ce que je mangeais pas pendant ma
préparation au prix fort ce que je
mangeais pas ce que j'aurais mangé le
parce que je me disais
tu aller t'entraîner toujours pas
commencé à
rapper sortent ces puits consciemment je
prenais cette décision-là puis je dire
je suis jetée
au sens où ce que tu ce que tu fais ces
réseaux sociaux je suis têtu j'adhère à
ça je trouve ça super pertinent fait
conscient que mes décisions puis quand
le cash je m'en empêcher de manger
quelque chose qui me tentait j'étais
conscient que c'était négatif mais que
le parcours puis de west que ça m'a mené
afin tout seul puisqu'il faisait que je
me levais des fois le matin en plus
mobilisés en tant que membre est un
objectif que tu veux pas aller
t'entraîner ne vous dis pas non je
voyais aller parce que parce que sinon
j'ai de la culpabilité pas étaler toute
la journée très probablement qui est
toxique
j'imagine mais qu'à fin du parcours
toutes ces micro décisions là de
culpabilité de de
comportement vraiment toxique m'ont
amené vers
fort quelque chose qui au final
maintenant et comme un plus énorme dans
ma vie tu fais comment est-ce qu'on
balance parce que je comprends je
comprends que healy après un petit
comportements qui sont old school mais
qui au final l'équation
[Rires]
musique comment comment conjoncture mais
c'est là que je suis comme un peu mêlé
dans tout ça parce que moi j'ai toujours
fonctionné même cas que j'allais au jim
cache dans le rouge et or ont ôté on
était un groupe ensemble ce look ce
point' et paulin il se le faisait dire
par toutes les autres pistes et genre
c'était ce qu'il faisait quand ça me
tentait pas de chez elle et y va ça
prenait de motivation externe parce que
c'est pas tout le temps en vrai que la
motivation est complète de l'intérieur
fait que j'ai fait qd c'est ça j'ai eu
peut-être même pas de question
non mais en fait c'est je parle et on
marathon qui je pense avait quand même
beaucoup exposé sur les réseaux sociaux
piété dans une position je pense qu il
différent de la moyenne des gens dans ce
sens où tu exposes bukut est justement
tu as progressons mais c'est sûr que je
veux peu foiré à la fin si c'est comme
tu le vraiment explosé j'étais je pense
que c'est aussi ça pète motivé de paix
le fujikai m'entraîner parce que j'étais
à tout le monde que ça mais ça sinon je
t'ai je me sentais coupable toute la
journée mais je faisais ce même avant
d'être acquis c'est même avant d'attirer
sociaux etc un carnage et je disais mes
objectifs haut et fort à tout le monde
parce que ça me garde des acanthes bol
des attentes fait que ça faisait que
quand ça me tentait pas
une fois sur quatre ça me ferait pas
d'aller m'entraîner mais ça me tente pas
encore aujourd'hui c'est une fois sur le
cadre mais ac mais c'est cette fois le
que ça me prend quelque chose d'externes
souvent si la culpabilité envers la
taille de mes objectifs mais ton mais
qu'au final quand je suis allée la
seconde que je mets les pieds chez nous
c'est positif c'est tout le temps puis
la seconde que je prends la décision de
ne pas aller au dépanneur me chercher un
sac de chip
bain aux stocks que l'adhésion et clara
ma tête je me sens bien c'est d'avoir
pris cette décision alors le ton mais
sûrement un moyen que tu pourrais
arriver au même résultat mais ton
d'entraînement puis d'alimentation sans
passer par le biais je suis là
discussions qu'ont eues les gens avec
jean-philippe iti zik lui ce qu'il dit
est comme toi avant mais qui est
kim et lui répondait t il a appris à pau
pour atteindre un bon pour surmonter
mais ton juste comme aller t'entraîner
juste pour le plaisir puis bien acquis
cet apport
mais c'est ce j'imagine qu'ils
pourraient recourir aux armes à feu je
sais pas en essayant de
fortis et qu'il y ait culpabilité comme
jamais tomber et je pense que oui pips
et dans mon coeur tu l'attends toujours
en compte quand même beaucoup de gens
qui est qui ont des troubles
alimentaires puis un des aspects des
fois d'un trouble alimentaire c'est une
activité physique excessive ça permet
souvent de père du pop compenser les
limites certains rapports
qui une des premières choses qu'on fait
c'est de retirer complètement l'activité
physique que l'on voit des comportements
alimentaires qui ressurgissent j'ai des
clients qui se mettra à priori c'est
très émotif de don magique puis cette
partie le le mon alimentation mon corps
qu'est ce qui va se passer puis
finalement être qu'on aimait le sport ou
est ce qu'on le faisait justement juste
parce que les starlettes à contrôler le
poids ou est ce que ça cache quelque
chose
l'activité physique ça devrait être fait
dans une tendance du plaisir
effectivement la culpabilité comme
motivation peut décemment qui plus est
le plus sain comme comme façon de se
motiver on peut penser ou après aussi tu
es dans ton cul s'entendent pas vraiment
mais après je me sens bien mais comme
d'un disque une autre façon de te motive
aller t'entraîner qui serait peut être
culpabiliser lampi centre est quand même
bien apprise
peut-être peut-être peut-être faudrait
il faudrait que je jouais mais on dirait
que c'est que je me dis
c'est pas un problème
mais ça me choque dans le fond parce que
théo dans la ville par la question et
leurs enfants et c'est tout qui sait non
mais c est parce que moi au quotidien
georges et déjà toujours été le même bus
que rec avec celui effectué habitués
m'étais je serais curieux justement
c'est comme quand tu veux mais tu
arrêtes le sport complètement devoir
laisse qu'il y ait des choses qui
ressurgit en
fait je sais que quand j'arrête le sport
mais ton quand j'ai une pause le ou
quand je prends le chemin neuf loges
thomas un animateur qui qui ce que je
parlais tantôt est ce que je me fais
livrer de la fois plus je regarde même
plus je mange vos jeux vos stores une
fois par jour aux matchs du bonbon et
puis tombe d'un jardin sur le cash flow
de sport mais
justement fait qu'on le retire qui est
il ya des comportements de mon père qui
ressurgissent de faire comme acquis
finalement le sport des com met en place
sur quelque chose qu'on le voyait peu
trop plein dans lève le placer au à
quillan beaubourg en dessous avec lui
c'est là que ça peut être intéressant
d'aller lui le travail nick wey la
différence je pense de toi petit et des
sportifs
mettons de haut niveau de compétition en
général c'est que si la finalité c'est
la performance les finalités cpo la
perte de paume et on le tue tandis que
je pense que pour
dépôt certaines personnes qui
s'entraînent ses cibles comme une
manière de contrôler justement leur
promettant le tri tandis que
toi l'entraînement puis l'alimentation
si comme ce qui vient servir d'atteindre
un objectif de performance et pays comme
l'inde nuancé différence le pis je
l'aimerais 5 avec le sport
si comme on apprend rapidement repris
les effets
sur notre corps de l'alimentation
peut-être plus directement mais tant que
quelqu'un qui ne fait pas du port
nautique comme jeune rapidement on se
rend compte qui est qui si je marche pas
par tout à l'entraînement je me rends
compte tout de suite à mon goût si je
marche vraiment trop entraînements je me
rends compte à marche post marge de quoi
qu' aimer ton qui se digère mal je te
rends compte c'est nous autres le
secondaire ont mangé à midi et demi à
une option mais déjà c'est bien on se
bourre à face de dassa nicole beaulieu
puis puis aux stocks iront manger un
aliment qui se digère est plus lentement
on leur hôtel toutefois la pratique le
fait qu'on avait jamais les mêmes tout
le temps les mêmes sa note globale de
pinottes
sur la forme du tibia pression
d'autres facteurs sens critique ce
moment donné on est allé s'entraîner on
n'avait pas dormi de la nuit on dit on
samedi matin c'est drôle était à piscine
5h30 si la star pour pratiquer des
histoires de cyclistes comme au
mexique m
rapidement c'est comme si comme claire
un peu qu'est-ce-qui bon pour toi tu
niveau habitude d'élite et puis après
c'est peut-être que tu reproches des
répressions que c'est peut-être moins
évident pour que pour quelqu'un qui fait
pas du sport de performance de com voit
aussi directement les effets
de ce qu'on mange peu nos habitudes de
vie sur notre santé dans le monde ouais
métis on parle le sport uniquement
dépendamment de fait c'est pas la
clientèle que je reçois le plus mais ça
peut m'arriver il ya moyen aussi de
faire des calendriers ses deux jambes et
une compétence un certain moment et
peut-être que le poids pour avoir un
enfant quand le ça dépend beaucoup de
bobigny tévelave inami dans l'ue les cas
justement l'un jean philippe d vous avez
accepté cph exhibé j'acceptais que
certaines disciplines sportives que je
serai pas le meilleur mais il ya des
athlètes qui vont voir perdre du poids
pour essayer justement d'aller chercher
indien est ce que c'est vraiment
significatif mais pas nécessairement
avec ça mais doit on peut faire des
calendriers justement t2 doit être par
rapport au poids tu va atteindre certain
poids pour une compétition incertaine et
eux mais ça va être juste pendant un
moment pendant une saison après se
retrouve une alimentation qui peut-être
justement moins encadré c'est d'avoir
cessé saison le lycée moment le ca
devrait pas être tout le temps et
restreints puis tout le temps contrôler
le alimentation par rapport à l'activité
physique oui en effet mais tu lui parles
d'un ami de l'activité
le sommeil
d'autres affaires qui ont un effet la
performance sportive mais souvent va
accuser l'alimentation le poids c'est
des facteurs ce qu'ils sont importants
mais c'est pas nécessairement eu combat
culte en les travail il s'est uniquement
est ce qui est approprié en une
technique et il ya d'autres choses qui
aident et à pâques sont justement la
technique c'est vraiment super bon
exemple peu importe c'est moi j'ai
coaché du monde la natation puis
il fallait qu'ils améliorent leur
technique bien avant toutes les autres
la chose numéro que le guen tellement
moins tellement moins marginal de relire
ici zafar locke de commencer à te
concentrer sur les macronutriments
de
pousser c'est pas tout le temps non plus
dans un sens en ce qui est des photos
vouloir pour la performance prendre pour
un train de la marge qui rappelle les
hollande joseph balle l'ex-rda 350 lits
plus en santé que moi
parlons un peu de ça parce que je sais
que le poids c'est quelque chose de kiki
et ocz et puis si jamais on jeudi
quelque chose dans le prochain 30
minutes qui fait aucun sens dit le moine
on avait reçus ici caraquet tu connais
peut-être avec kim dans le fond car on
travaille chez équilibreront puis dans
le fond le consensus à sortir sas et
commentaires sur le poids sinon se tait
vie dans ces évidentes c'est calme
maintenant mais dans ce sens mais tombe
trop
pour nous on est ce parce qu'ils coûtent
de podcasts ses évidentes mais ce ça
veut pas dire parlons plus du tout pour
puis où est ce que je dois emmener avec
ça c'est que
si on mélange ces deux idées l'homme
étant de commentaires sur le pauvre le
versus pour moi en général ça peut
devenir quand même
dangereux au sens je donne une coupe
d'exemple nous sont arrivés ici sur le
podcast
on a reçu un gars qui s'appelle jean
alain brouillette quitte comme l'a fait
deux post doctorat sur l'alzheimer
l'oeil connaisseur
demande c'est quoi tes les facteurs à
éviter les facteurs de risque le lui dit
le poids dans 30 salle listings puis
vous dérangera pas l'obstiné il connaît
ça pleut dans les commentaires sur
youtube on se fait de l'oeil ses
segments la grossophobie plomb fait
qu'est mais en même temps premièrement
spawns autres qui le disons et
deuxièmement le gueut j'imagine qu'ils
doivent savoir de quoi il parle un petit
après ça autre exemple parce qu'on soit
2 physio qui viennent ici le pin ou
inutilisés qu'est ce qu'on fait on va
les deux lois chronique de l'offre nous
l'apprenait qui dit le poids c'est un
facteur surtout sur les douleurs du beau
du corps aussi parce que tout au plus de
poids à traîner un peu plus de chance de
blessures plus encore une fois ne
commentons ce segment des grosses fautes
pileux mais je me dis
c'est une grosse faute que de parler de
choses qui sont statistiquement
statistiquement vrai par rapport au
poids que je peux comprendre que
pour une personne grosse entendent ce
site offre puis je comprends absolument
sauf qu'en même temps est ce que
on arrête de parler de ces effets le
juste parce que on arrête de faire des
commentaires sur le poids peut situer
encore une fois on garde ça en tête que
c'est ultra les gypsies que le culte de
la minceur c'est extrêmement toxique de
vouloir aller et demi c'est la paix est
la partie toute seule c'est des acquis
le fait que si vous écoutez le podcast
entre humains vous pensez que c'est pas
des acquis sans harnais pour nous sommes
que le tir tout ça c'est stupide ça
prend une diversité corporelle
clairement comme je disais les
hollandais de 350 livres sont plus en
santé que moi je l'étais enfin neuf le
pot un bon indicateur de santé lee
daniels restrictif avoir gelé d'y être
et rester sarah pas pardon de l'ocs et
partant de leur ferons notre souhait de
le toux courbatures partons de tss mais
après ce je pense que c'est important
quand même de poser la question faut
qu'on peut sans parler c'est comme on
peut comme on peut parler encore une
fois comme tu disais aucun jugement gbin
des amis que feu moi même je fume de
temps en temps
mais fois capable de dire que la
cigarette c'est pas bon il faut être
capable de dire que ça peut déclencher
des cancers ça peut faire ça peut faire
ce qu'est ce qu'on fait avec poids dans
des situations mais moi ce que le gain
est une sommité mondiale dans
l'alzheimer pile 10 et ses pipes il y en
a d'autres exemples le trac la plupart
des sujets de santé qu'on a parlé
quelques on parlait des facteurs de
risques ça fait sa participation encore
là c'est parce ça faisait partie pis
t on le sait pour commence à connaître
aussi les gens qui nous écoutent puis
elles sont un sujet car chaque fois
qu'on parle de vous comprenons certes un
mot encore sur les messages sur ceux des
maîtres des emails une message aux
commentaires des gens qui comprennent
mais ce type
puis je me dis oh nous éduquer oui c'est
pis je comprends je comprends qu'ils
aient
d'un côté d'en parler ça contribue à la
culpabilité ça contribue à
l'environnement le défaut maigrir quand
je suis seul je comprends
sauf qu était le gars qui est qu'ils
disent aux suppôts de caste diapo pas
sortie seule de son début la cepi joukov
passe quelque chose quand tu es
personnes grosses liquidités pas pu
parce qu'ils veulent et discriminés et
c'est parce que selon les études selon
une méta analyse d'études on se rend
compte que s'il ya un lien à plébisciter
simplement de tendre pourcentage de
chances de 6,4 6,6 très c'est très
objectif le tiki eux cadencés sans
jugement avec après the question
persique qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ce
qu'il faut éviter dire saint-prix d'en
parler parce que ça peut avoir un effet
néfaste sur certaines personnes nous
faut quand même le dire parce que c'est
vrai oui m mais qui vient en fait de
temps que j'ai beaucoup aimé te dis je
demande c'est le poids ya un lien avec
des restes et des promesses ne sont pas
la cause les associations mais la
corrélation ça explique pau fabuleux
qu'est ce que tu fais que le poids on
n'est pas capable de faire les études
qui explique sans vielle donc sans et
enlever tout lé bien dedans mais qu'est
ce qui fait que le poids justement par
exemple pourquoi le poids comment le
port en effet sur le développement
précoce de rasage mais il ya tellement
de billets que c'est vraiment difficile
de dire si c'est vraiment la faute du
poids il ne tombiez en jeu il y a comme
un lien mais on peut peut l'expliquer
fax et le ou qui jetait dans la tumeur
ni un site qui existe qui est vraiment
très drôle qui en fait sa montre
justement plainte corrélation des
données
jeanny violent qui a sorti récemment
c'est le nombre d'apparitions de films
le nombre de films que nichols quel jeu
fait par ami avec le nombre de morts par
noyade en piscine pied une corrélation
qui est très forte entre les deux
je suive énormément mais je vais unique
au losc et je n'explique pas pourquoi il
ya des morts par noyade
mais c'est un peu se tait ses farces
loin mais c'est un peu ça aussi on verra
avec le poids de dire ben oui peut avoir
des corrélations qui paraît très forte
mais ça ne l'expliquent quand même pas
donc le foie rivoire mais d'abord qu'est
ce qui fait que le poids en reste et
effet le une carnation ça veut juste
dire que ses associés messi qui
s'annulent et ça n'explique pas ce jeu
juste après que j'accepte ce mais qu'est
ce qui explique la corrélation est selon
toi en général mais ce qu'on sait et il
ya une chose je sais pas ça et déjà
entendu parler du sol et c'est quand
même assez pointu mais on parle de la
charge allostatique
avec 9 en
2010 j'ai voilà tu parles je pense avec
robert
c'est un effet en fait l'effet cumulatif
du stress sur le corps et ça sera un bon
prédicteur justement du développement de
maladies chroniques
qu'est ce qu'on observe que la charge
allostatique est très élevée chez les
personnes qui ont un poids qui prix
élevés parce qu'ils vivent la cimade
façon parce qu'ils vivent dans un
environnement qui nie pas fait pour eux
il ya une charge allostatique qui très
élevé fonctionnement est ce que c'est le
poids qui fait qu' ils sont malades ou
est ce que c'est bien le stress
chronique qui vive parce qu'ils sont
dans un corps plus gros qui fait que
sont malades mais mettons mais tant que
ça peut être dit textuellement sauf que
c'est une association qui a été fait
mais tant de
par rapport aux deux exemples que j'ai
nommé tantôt les deux physio qui sont
une grotte dit que le poisson même
tension supplémentaire sur les
articulations du beau du corps qui font
que tu peux développer des maladies
chroniques des des problèmes chroniques
d'articulation plus rapidement certains
ceci c'est une observation que d'autres
ont fait c'est fait c'est fait que c'est
une cause si le poids serait une cause
de développer d'aider des malades et des
problèmes d'articulation plus rapidement
parce que c'est un stress de plus de
spéculation plus tu prends se dit que
l'acteur une douleur chronique belote
c'est sûr que tu tombes dans un pactole
de vie plus sédentaire parce que telle
mais un peu plus de difficulté à bouger
puis ce problème de vie sédentaire là
peut amener à moins bouger puis moins
bouger c'est comme la première affaire
jusqu'à des maladies dégénératives comme
alzheimer parkinson c'est chose fait qd
il le chemin se fait quand même eux ne
sais pas comme complètement farfelu de
d'imaginer que ça peut être une cause si
précieux qu'est ce qui est ce qui
t'amène le
cénotaphe averti sauf que j'ai
l'impression qu'elle dit il comme trop
c'est comme 3 arrivé souvent que c'est
me comme étant un facteur de risque pour
que ce soit juste complètement random
j'ai l'impression le dessus non c'est
pas vendeur mais c'est drôle moi
j'entends des fissures qui disaient le
contraire avec le faudrait vraiment les
vendant littérature qui en est
réellement la loi sur les articulations
autres tout se sait de dire en sachant
que dévier de sa marche peut on fait
coiffer encore lire j'ai l'impression
qu'on pointe du doigt les gens devaient
se faire la main avant je travaille pour
être gros ouais mais comment tu le
choixpeau gros c'est ici comme là 70% de
notre pays décider par notre génétique
puis apprécier plein d'autres facteurs
qui rentrent dans ce qui détermine mon
poids taxer l'eau je trouve ça d'une
certaine façon ça peut être pas perdu en
études doctorat qui gesticulent
islesmere le post un facteur de risque
qu'est ce que le une association c'est
vraiment sale explique ranko prochaine
on fait quoi avec ce passé seul le
projet puis je me dis ces supports
pertinents les études scientifiques
c'est là où je suis plus sur les
terrains des unes des clients me disent
souvent tes jeux pas développer des
maladies tout mais j'ai acquis mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait le entre les
connaissances mais la réalité de tu peux
pas en perdre du poids comment est-ce
qu'on peut justement trouver un juste
milieu puis des nuances entre les deux
mais je pense que je pense qu'à la fin a
fait tout ce qu'on vient de dire le on
pourrait effacer les dix dernières
minutes de notre conversation puis le on
encourage des habitudes de vie saines au
final le tue la faune aussi c'est assez
rare qu'on peut faire parce qu'il ya peu
pâteux peut pas
viser une perte de potes tu peux juste y
aller par le positif en faisant soyons
tous +19 en tête devient donc en
caresser selon la décision de la
personne c'est là où encore c'est la
santé ça devrait pas est une vertu s'il
peut être parce que je pense contexte
une même personne
si la personne consciemment des sites de
bavans des saines habitudes de vie qui
est consciente de ce que ça le est le
toutes les informations c'est s'il ya
aussi on ne connaît pas mieux si ça
vient quand même touché 2
comme posture sociétaire de dire si tu
veux prendre des habitudes de vie qui
sont mal si tu as le droit de le faire
tu peux le faire parce que
fondamentalement on a toujours le droit
sauf qu' on est quand même
on est quand même dans le système de
santé universel dans un échec de
commencer à dire tu pas grata décision
personnelle a pas d'impact sur sa
décision de ne pas d'avoir des habitudes
de vie malsaines a pas d'impact sur la
société c'est plus ou moins vrai que
j'ai c'est un argument j'entends
beaucoup justin marché quoi tu réponds
vraiment justes qui en mettant la santé
comme une vertu sadi encore une fois que
ça va tellement revenir la culpabilité
sa vie la culpabilité des fauches en son
temps à tout prix tandis que quand on
enlève cette pression le naturel je
connais pas grange grandjean qui
naturellement nous voulons faire des
choses qui vont affecter leur est la
leur ville qu'ils vainquent ce qu'ils
vont affecter leur santé physique ou
psychologique je connais pas beaucoup de
gens qui sont dans ce cas qu'est-ce que
ça va vraiment affecté les systèmes de
santé qu'on ne je penserais pas le
prévient m
je connais ce monde qui déteste faire du
sport je déteste bouger mais tant pis
je trouve que c'est quand même
important plus pertinent
d'essayer de d'inculquer des de trouver
des façons de bouger différentes même si
la personne veut rien savoir le tuer je
trouve c'est quand même important qu'on
puisse en tant que société diriger un
bureau dirigé mais qu'on puisse avoir
une panoplie de choses à proposer pour
que tout le monde plus même si leur
temps de pause bien trouver une façon de
bouger parce que tu mettes ont bougé
ceci hors de tout doute une affaire
qu'il faut que tu fasses le cdh en vie
mais qu'il faut que tu fasses et bozik
hors de tout d'autres positive l'oedt
ces menaces tu veux pas le faire libre à
toi de paul fort par contre je trouve
que suppose une posture difficile en
tant que société dacic d'accepter ce que
de dire good faisant partie oui non mais
je suis d'accord c'est ça nous rend
inconfortable mais je pense qu'ils
étaient par l'activité physique
quelqu'un qui aime post c'est le travail
des cliniciens que ce soit c'est moi
comme nutritionnistes les psychologues
les fusées ou les ergots propos mais
celle aussi de comprendre pourquoi tu
bouges
pourquoi t'as pas ce comportement les
tice que je te demande tu peux trouver
quelque chose que tu aimes est une
personne grosse va peut-être se sentir
mal dans l'eau jim parce qu'elles
veulent regarder ofac et most-hid les ya
plus de questions que ce mais je pense
qu'il faut pour vendre le point de
bouger ou de manger de manière intuitive
comme une façon d'atteindre la santé
puis l'odeur mais finalement la santé ça
vient de remplacer le corps mince avance
était comme on voulait faire des
magasins pour avoir un corps mince
laisse qu'on a on a substitué stade je
fais des actions pour rappel la santé
puis genevard en morale qui est
supérieur parce que moi je suis en santé
je trouve que c'est un ferment donc non
je pense que ces deux qui ont une valeur
morale supérieure parce qu'on est en
santé mais je pars je pense juste que
c'est comme ça on a un malaise à dire
c'est quoi
les lésés bonnes actions à prendre de
manière générale pour être en santé mais
ton bouger bien manger
6e mettons ce jour le médecin puis j'ai
dit je devrais dessus arrêter de fumer
ou devrais je prendre six points
puis kiêm dit les brosses tu veux tu
fais ce que tu veux tu fais juste que tu
veux dans le fond c'est comme je
l'utilisé toile expertise justin disent
qu'est ce qui est bon qu'on boit le thé
taxer
c'est juste que je pense que après seul
encore une fois libre aux gens de
prendre l'information oui je pense quand
même que lors des informations des
copies manger c'est dans ton exemple je
reprendre ton exemple avec les médecins
le médecin actuellement devrait te dire
les médicaments voici ce qui fait voici
avantages les inconvénients est ce que
tu veut le prendre il va pas te dire
prendre les médicaments si ton médecin
comme ça
j'en connais pas de médecin fait qu'ils
sont comme cela personnellement mais
absolument c'est d'exposer au niveau de
l'activité physique ça même chose
l'activité physique c'est en fait voici
les bienfaits puis ben si tu me fais de
manière culpabilisant de voici les
effets secondaires prend la question tu
amènes si c'est vraiment de redonner un
peu le pouvoir aux gens d'avoir cette
édition là au lieu de leur imposer de
faire des choses puis justement
d'essayer de les culpabiliser affaires
d'une action et il fait prendre des
décisions humaines mais c'est clair que
c'est pas la culpabilité que il faut que
ça va se faire c'est trop
trouvé de renforcement positif
de ce pays si les gentlemen que james
pas pour eux qui ont essayé puis mpc
lopy sauve qui est mon deuxième set en
or il ya le souhaitent dans le bois
batterie d'autres activités - pour
bouger une différence si vous trouvez
s'ériger des gens qui qui se disent bien
moi je vais juste j'aurais juste la
place cette semaine pour bouger une fois
mais c'est pas assez fait que je le
ferai juste pas parce qu'elles ont la
perception qu'il faut que je m'entraîne
un minimum de trois heures par semaine
en étant cet été mais une fois je trouve
c'est déjà mieux que pas du tout ça leur
faisait plaisir enfin il ya toutes ces
messages le qui justement c'est
culpabilisant je peux juste le faire une
fois puisque pas correct selon les noms
je le ferai pas mais une fois ça aurait
pu être par personne absolument
g
absolument je comprends moi maintenant
je vais je vais
avidement là à la recherche de
c2c guideline l'homme dont les gars line
de genre bouger trois fois par semaine
dont j'ai tant d'enfants temps de
protéines selon ton pour mettons outils
dormir dormir ce n'est un bon le sait
combien d'heures faut que tu dormes qui
est le genre de qualité de sommeil puis
moi j'essaie de
d'aller chercher d'aller chercher ce le
plus possible de baser mes décisions un
peu sur ceux
sur ce que je sais qu'il va être
finalement pour ma santé physique le
mieux donc mais foutu conserve sa santé
mentale ouais sauf que moi c'est comme
j'aime
ça me procure du bien et pika mettant
j'ai une bonne une bonne nuit de sommeil
qui respecte mon but en or et on le fait
que je me sens bien c'est quand je suis
bien et puis
je dois pas être le seul mais je pense
pense pas que je suis seul qui doit
fonctionner le maton dans ville du puy
puis j'ai l'impression que
j'ai l'impression que le cam est en jeu
je parle de ceux où que quand tu changes
10e j'ai comme l'impression qu'il ya une
espèce de
point bâclage une espèce de
deux
de problèmes que les gens avec ce mets
ton avec la nouvelle tendance
comme d'autres qu'on parle depuis tout à
l'heure le tir puis j'ai l'impression
que c'est comme un le retour du
balancier de l'autre bord que la magie
moi je m'intéresse à ces choses le plus
j'ai l'impression que tu investis
craquer qui comme une scène biki qui
juste parce qu'ils essaient d'avoir
toutes les meilleures habitudes de vie
saines selon ce que ce que la science
dit pour mon corps et ont mangé la
petite critique est pas de bon sens là
dessus bibi sur moi c'est de la
culpabilité l'autre sens si j'ai
l'impression que c'est quand même un peu
par la culpabilité mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu le
je me sens comme un peu dans marge
mettons maintenant à temps et que lui ce
qu'il faut que tu fasses c'est qui je
parle jamais de ces affaires là faut
qu'il y ait pas tu fais ce qui est bon
pour toi puis l'homme sait comment
maîtrise moi j'aimerais ça avoir moi
comme les statistiques puis les données
puis j'aimerais c'est s'il ne le connais
tu le fait que j'agisse comment conjugue
l'eau si avec ça parce que je vais
pression que moi mais ton meilleur
exemple
juste on en parlait l'autre fois mais
juste les pages instagram que je suis
mais ton j je suis conscient que plein
de pages qui sont super pertinente que
je suis pas parce que
c'est pas fait c'est pas pour moi
mettons le dit les pages de de schumann
liszt et
des culpabilités le tc correct de rester
chez vous mais ton cas qu'il fait beau
un dimanche puisque moi j'aime sûr que
me faire dire l effet qu en lice mambo
dimanche je m'étais jogging va courir tu
voyais déjà au top job du monde entier
le tri fait que c'est quelque chose j'ai
trouvé sauf qu'en même temps je pense
pas qu'il faut je pense ça reste quand
même une façon légitime de voir le truc
là je sais pas si ça fait dix ans que je
dis bof qui était que pour toi t'es tu
retrouvé qu'est ce qui marche et puis
qu'est ce qui te fait du bien puis j'ai
l'impression que je sais rendu justice
est rendue
mais c'est que la culture dj
c'est ma tante je sais pas trop dans
quel là je pense qu'on peut trop triste
c'est quand j'étais jeune la culture
dédié étaient autour de moi c'est très
clair ok c'est pour perdre du poids en
bosnie ouais pige en main sa vie
qui maintenant ça s'est beaucoup
transformée en un pc je demande que le
royaume est d'ailleurs le fait d'avoir
déçu personne d'habitudes de vie mais si
15 6 pouces encore une fois dans un
extrême de bâtiments je tombe sur nos
petits bols le matin
surtout des filles que je vois que tu
dois faire tomber la tête tu veux si tu
fais ce que tu veux être en santé pied
vers le mans ressemble et souvent c'est
des films un style fonceur c'est l'os
est revenue quand même une forme dédiée
pour dc correct de vouloir dormir c'est
correct de vouloir s'entraîner ses
doigts c'est quoi la motivation derrière
ce encore risque dans un objectif de
poids le je parle en général paint
serment toi tes excuses dans un objectif
de poids
mais c'est que je me demanderais été les
gens qui trouvent craqué en fait plus
par rapport à toi ce serait de voir tes
à quoi ça sert d'avoir des informations
le c'est qui qui pourrait te faire peur
et je demande 10 mais d'autres majorités
d'écouter mon corps par rapport à fou je
me fie à mon application qui me dis-je
assez dormi il faut que je me fie à mon
application qui est déjà assez mangé ton
corps est cette capacité le tattoo
l'indiqué textes souvent c'est plus sur
les questions que ça m'amène qu'on
utilise des outils extérieur ça peut
être intéressant mais qu'est ce qui nous
fait part à essayer d'écouter notre
corps c'est en fait je peux répondre
pour moi méme et puis évidemment pas
pour personne d'autre le mais c'est moi
je lis les fois où est ce que j'écoute
mon corps puis mata est où est ce que je
me dis ah je vais écouter un autre et un
autre épisode de mon émission de squid
games typique que l'aï rendu 2h30 la
nuit fiche sur netflix est au fin fond
d'un trou sans fond que le lendemain je
signe mon cadran et a eu le temps puis
je sais que le jeu vient d'écouter ma
tête parce que ça me tentait de faire ça
mais je sais que demain matin je vais
avoir la tête dans le cul je dois être
pas efficaces va être poche dans ce que
je fais je dois être moins réveillé puis
que le de savoir que ça me prend 8
heures ça me permet vraiment amener de
mettre une barrière de faire genre
acquis non le même si j'en ai coûterait
un autre intuitivement faut je me couche
eu parce que même si je suis pas fatigué
même si j'ai encore ben ali mais faut je
me couche parce que je sais qu est ce
que ça va faire demain sinon c'est non
ce oui mais plus dans le sens des ses
matons toi ça prend 8 heures mais il ya
des gens que ça va en prendre c'est
qu'il ya des gens sans prendre neuf maxi
plus le je parlais dans les côtes du cap
sur le moment choisi était issu par
stimule avant d'accoucher kit endormir
peu mais de dire et je me rends compte
que mon général s'en prend à peu près
entre ces petits maîtres à 8h30 mais si
ce jeu mais en plus c'est quand même
intervalle qui il faut que ma stats
répondent précisément où recherche celle
aussi comme ça d'ici paris j'y mets
toute la question qu'il faut se poser
est ce que tout ça
toutes ces intérêts look top ses
habitudes le pied c'est
un peu cette régie pas cette rigidité
mais est
ce que
pour pour les bienfaits de ma santé
physique que vous est-ce que ce que
c'est tellement intense que évidemment
sa demie une autre fois de ta vie ou ou
non cette finale la santé ça sera à être
bien admis e pierre plus heureux pendant
le v8 et puis si la réponse est oui ben
si la réponse est non pas ce qui au
final je te sa nuit tu as 30 aspach
social bly sacré de l'anxiété au jour le
jour parce que ça c'est top c'est bon
mais on peut laisser les gens vivent
aussi bassiste
et locke c'était un peu là je voulais en
venir au site c'est dans le sens je
pense que c'est important de trouver qu
est-ce qui tue qu'est-ce qui toi te
permet d'être bien dans le fond mais
après ce
message c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
faire
puis on se rend pas compte que c'est que
je pense entre autres aux troubles
alimentaires c'est une plante qui est
très glissante pour les comme des petits
blocs lego tanger jenca pardon tout
comme un jeu judd gregg s'additionnent
pour m'amener l'entourent attendre d'un
trou ballmer pas que c'est quand même de
rester conscient de cette évolution le
sait très insidieux la culture dédié
glisser vers un trouble mental aussi
c'est super insidieux accès quand même
de rester ouvert à échanger justement de
dire ben ma position je vais pas rester
camper son imposant qu'il faut que je
donc tant que je mange tant que
peut-être effectivement juste un peu
figé depuis je pourrais amener des
changements mais au final si c'est ce
qui nous fait du bien on peut laisser
les gens vivre mais correct si c'est ça
mon travail de dire honnêtement match
amical qu'est ce que toi tu veux
atteindre on veut se rendre le jeu dit
pas moi je vais aller en quelque sorte
que tu me suis là comme qu'est ce que tu
vas te ferait sentir bien et puis bah
des fois c'est sûr que dans ma tête
comme on aurait peut être pu travailler
ce ça des fois je le mentionne son camp
mais je ponds intéressées elles sont pas
intéressés c'est correct lui
bien les gens qui viennent te voir
j'imagine ce parce qu'il ya un petit
quelque chose quelque part iggy pop qui
sont insatisfaits une petite avance
quelques parlementaires
viennent te voir parce qu'ils le
trouvaient ce mais qui s'émousse
l'étagé la pente glissante dans le déni
que chez peu mes comportements
alimentaires comment ils peuvent
affecter facts il ya quand même sa garde
en tête d'où la pertinence et quelque
chose comme aujourd'hui d'échangés de
rester couvert deux équipes est qu'est
ce que je fais c'est moins intéressant
que ce que je pensais
pour rester ouverts à ça parce que comme
j'ai eu quand même beaucoup de déni mais
après cela personne est très consciente
puis ça lui fait du bien il peut dénier
les comportements sont sains pour elle
même si ça va à l'encontre de moi ce que
j'aurais fait cette personne là eh bien
on va la laisser vivre
sur ta page instagram on parlait du
surpoids avant de commencer le podcast
vont parler du mot surpoids qu'il
n'était des ul parce que dans toute
affaire le pour éviter de
la culpabilisation des jeunes j'imagine
qu'il ya plein d'affaires dans notre
vocabulaire qu'il faut être attentif je
suis persuadé que comme moi le surpoids
en lisant ton posé fait effectivement
que ça fait aucun fois qu'un centre de
parler de surpoids qui indiquerait que
ruse pour normal puis c'est ça c'est un
vieux ça devient une facture une fois
que tu comprends mieux ce message est ce
qu il yad autres afin qu'il faut faire
attention c'est dans notre langage
quotidien l'été pour éviter de de
blessés ou de dire de quoi que je sais
politique ouais quand même on entend
parler justement avant puissions nommer
style si j'utilise encore des mots que
je corrige aussi les gens dans sa venue
le but c'est poggi pas la police puis
ses potes pointant encore une fois du
doigt les gens je pense que juste d'en
être conscient que le mot qu'on choisit
bain peut créer de la culpabilité de la
stimulation chez des gens taxe est sûre
que tout ce qui sur poissy bah c'est
juste parce par intéressant gros gros tu
sais plus mais peu mitigé mais il ya des
gens qui aiment se le réapproprient
comme on les personnes grosse m se
réapproprier des gens qui sont gros
gross qui souhaitent pas l'utiliser vexé
c'est vraiment plus à la discrétion de
la personne qui dans le corps le haut
niveau du poids c'est surtout son
obésité aussi qui arrivent terme moi
dans ma pratique j'utilise poste mots le
jeu trouvera encore une fois ci pas
stigmatisant parce qu ils vraiment basé
selon la charte de
celui des yeux comme com donne ici c'est
très désuet comme comme d'infecter tout
ce qui entre et avec l'imc justement
surpoids obésité
je sais que c'est controversé des gens
qui l'utilisent puis qui aiment
l'utiliser mais moi dans ma pratique en
one je trouve qu'ils aient encore une
fois c'est super symathisants pic c'est
possible pertinent le jeu de dire
pourquoi classé la personne des gens qui
sont en pleurs qui me disait selon mon
imc et obésité est à 3 en quoi ces
pertinentes liste de paye formation le
fait juste le mot obèses en général
j'aime vraiment peu avec les racines
aussi qu elle l est comme la lame la
façon que le mot était comme construit
l'été c'est super tu maintenant fait que
obèses ou s'ils ont peut-être envie de
câbles
rmc site c est ce que c'est ça qui était
utilisé pour
qu'un les premiers vaccins sont sortis
depuis qu'il fallait que tu as eu une
[Musique]
mise en route certaines
des plus à risque donc été vaccinées
s'il est utilisé dans le fait que
david tantôt par rapport ait été au
poids comme facteur de risque il y
aurait observé dans certaines catégories
de poids selon l'imc que des risques
sont plus élevés encore l'assistance
moment c'est pas consensus au niveau de
la santé beaucoup d'études qui remette
son nom qui sait qu'il remette un peu
sont en question
fax pour ce que les gens justement qui
avait une imc qui était plus élevée par
la star ac ce n'est pas ce qui est
peut-être plus de facteurs de risque
mais lienz en soit ce n'est pas un outil
qu'on devrait utiliser dans des one on
one avec le médecin c'est pas quelque
chose qui devrait être utilisée était le
but battre de vraiment longtemps cet
indicateur loupe step pas à des fins
individus elle s'était vraiment passé
puis bref l'histoire de lienz et je
pense que justicier assez horrible mais
c'est pas quelque chose qui est très
pertinent parce que c'est vrai ce que
j'entendais parler de la grossophobie
médical qui était comme un fléau énorme
quand que les gens veulent les gens gros
ouais sauf que met-on garneau qui
veulent pas
fait que maintenant les gens gros kiki
qui vont dans un bureau de médecin pour
se faire traiter pour x ou y à fond le
médecin prend même pas le temps
d'analyser comme du monde plus juste
mais dessus sur la taille de la personne
pour le match 6 ou si c'est un top servi
justement quel les personnes grosses qui
vont subir de la grossophobie médicale
ben ils vont aller aux médecins et vont
attendre justement espace télévisé puis
après sont justement encore là en
sciences dont di bello les personnes
grosses ont plus de problèmes de santé
mais que ce parce qu'ils y ont évité
d'aller au médecin parce que quand ils
vont ils sont peu fr les tests qui sont
pertinentes puis ils sont juste des
biens par des poutres fait correct il ya
toutes ces enjeux là aussi le hac ans
terry
chez versace ses
soucis c'est en tout ce qui me perdre de
pot ça marche pas oui
ça marche pas ça marche pas jamais ça
marche pas une perte de poids volontaire
ça fonctionne peu parce que si on
l'oublié souvent mais on est tellement
d'années d'évolution derrière nous le
corps mis en place le tellement de
mécanismes pour survivre que de manière
volontaire si j'essaie de perdre du
poids le cas le faire on est en
situation qui nécessite que j'active
mais mécanisme de survie il voudra pas à
long terme que je perde du post axa veut
mettre en jeu ma survie après ce jeu peu
perdus pas prendre raison de maladie je
peux perdre pas parce que niveau ma
santé mentale ça va moins bien au
contraire ça vaut mieux il ya des pertes
de poids comme ceux qui peuvent arriver
mais ça va être involontaire mais deux
si je décide dans l'âme en paix j'ai
envie de perdre 5 lire les mécanismes
que je vais mettre en place on se met
très conscient depuis mon corps
automatismes en mode survie ya quelque
chose qui marche pas mais mais
car il a l'histoire des gens qui perdent
pas mes tantes et des gens qui changent
le type de vie complètement puis qui ont
une perte de poids oui c'est super mais
comme je ne sais pas volontaire si ta
motivation à faire l'activité physique
c'est la paire de postes en marche un
peu sur sa faim activité physique en
automne absolument dit à peu près
changer telle est une habitude pourrait
prendre à peu près deux ans devant après
deux ans et le convoité ci s'est bien
intégré d'un activité physique qui
mènera une perte de poids ben on va
regarder ça après deux trois ans que
c'est encore le système super intense
dans le but de perdre du poids est
souvent ça serait pure la personne a
atteint son objectif comment cette
fatigue qui aiment vraiment plus le
sport pascal fait de manière trop
intensive
comment ça se passe et les séances
qu'elle va reprendre son poids en
quelques clics et
tout ce qui
tout ce qui tend pas grave thématique
jeffrey j'aime pendant un mois je
passais des jus coin où je fais loose
tonnes par an et oui cela n'a fait que
tout à fond c'est ce qui fonctionne pas
parce que chargé ses habitudes de vie
sur le long terme oui mais ça se peut
que non si si je peux vendre leur être
non plus et j'ai beaucoup de clients qui
pensent qu'elles mentent à saint tite
tester la nouvelle façon de perdre du
poids c'est pas parce que tu écoute ton
corps que tu bouges par plaisir puisque
toutes ces aspects là que tu as perdu
paul petit peu chance d'avoir des appuis
de vitré celles soutenant la santé ouais
faut certainement s'en sort mieux peut
être en santé plafond si ceux ci haut
niveau ainsi que les effets secondaires
de détresse sur la perte de poulx
explique nos métiers la star de la ligue
1 sous le capot c'est ben oui
effectivement mais si c'est la finalité
dans le fond la finalité devrait jamais
être le pot de rett jose
être en santé vous sentir bien oui mais
j'imagine qu'il ya du monde qui changent
leurs habitudes de vie ou kiki qui
décident de chance d'avoir des
changements d'habitudes de vie
à cause d'eux
à cause de la vie que la vision que la
société envoie
du poids dans le fond le jeu mais john
carney qui arrive puisqu'elle a mené ces
dix mois mais le fossé le fameux faux je
me reprenne en main le jeu me reprenne
en main il pleut c'est pas faux je perds
du poids mais c'est comme il faut je
ferai quelque chose ma vie qui me rend
pas heureux fait que je me reprenne en
moins que je change mes habitudes de vie
tu sais mais ça me reprend moins ça dur
tu non mais c'est comme les risques de
mission et surtout l'ifo pis je dois un
peu je veux j'ai envie d'aller au front
parce que tout est encore le cd forme de
règle et comme on me dit que je dois
faire ce il faut que je fasse tous les
pas et j'ai envie d'explorer quels
actifs ici dit que me ferait plaisir
mais j'ai envie d'explorer les fruits
les légumes c'est quelque chose que je
connais pas beaucoup j'ai envie
d'explorer c'est possible ça tiendrait
pas parce que baisser encore une fois le
fait prendre motivation quitterait
extérieure à nous on me dit qu'il
fallait que je fasse je le fais c'est
pas une motivation qui interne et pas
très solide ça va se diffuser rapidement
sur tout on n'a pas de résultats il ya
des gentils que vont faire les 10 qui
auront peu de résultats bien lieu après
ce à maintenir des restrictions quant au
peu de résultats et ça fonctionne plus
je comprends
dit que le pour 70% de notre
peau est décidée par des facteurs
génétiques
donc il ya des gentils
qui naturellement son il se permet des
gens qui sont gros naturellement 1,6 et
sur leur
corps leurs normes à au bâton
puis ok on va parler en nutrition
seulement de poids naturel
je sais que c'est quelque chose qu'ils
avaient entendu parler mais c'est un
intervalle de poids justement dans
lequel une personne qui tire des
habitudes de vie qui lui font du bien
ben va vendre certaines intervalle de
poids qui pour ce que j'aime palier mais
qui peut être à l'extérieur depuis poids
santé en guillemets établi par l'imc
mais cette personne va s'entraîner vos
bougez vous sentir bien veut manger des
choses qui lui font sentir bien veut
avoir des super beau bilan sanguin pour
être un top santé physique mentale
sociale mais encore une fois selon le
médecin mais veut dire le selon la
charte type en santé et son poids
naturel pourtant est dans quelque chose
qui lui amène beaucoup de bien chaud
pis le dans ce col ça serait juste le
médecin qui tirait faudrait de fautes
pas du pot à cause que mal la charte le
dîner qu' aucun autre problème de santé
ça serait de voir le port comme quelque
chose de
soi qui finalement
aucun problème de santé c'est quelque
chose qui est très fréquent des ma
clientèle et beaucoup de gens qui
justement se fondit en béton poids c'est
faux que tu changes à tout prix mais la
personne à lui maintenu son poids
pendant des années est vraiment contente
a super bien incapable de profiter de la
vie berry ce pourquoi reste très basse
pour l'heure c'est quoi le mariage
homosexuel des fois je me demande c'est
quoi le marais ce qu'on a à z cette
personne là peut être bien son poids
puis après tu te sens tu à son pauvre
type pourquoi ça viennent confronter
puis faut absolument comme quessoy mind
pour qu'on la sociale à sans doute que
l'on l'acceptent
fasse un petit miles austin
j'ai l'impression
mellul en fait c'est super confrontant
comme conversation quand ma vie
mais je me dis
on parle demain ce pic du pin gros
depuis tantôt l'aimé mais
est-ce que y'a quand même est-ce qu'il
ya un an si tu parles du 110 % qui
génétique l'insee j'imagine que your way
n'jikam
dans la génétique parce qu'il a oublié
le mot obame et on commence on
si on en oublie le mot sur pau aussi
fait car le fossé semble ce qui n'est en
fait pas tout dire mais tant pis si j'ai
de la misère à part que le corps humain
à être humain il fait pour être ni
extrêmement minces ou extrêmement gros
match c'est sûr que je veux je veux dire
à 110% il joue dans un rêve jeté dans le
sens où
corrigez moi si je me trompe mais j'ai
pas l'impression que génétiquement tu
peux art être extrêmement grotti parce
qu'on parle on obtient on tu parles du
corps qui est en mode survie lui et puis
qui je dois quand même la génétique
derrière ce qu'on ait des des animaux
qui sont supposés se déplacer en courant
rapidement de façon à gilles évidemment
on peut regarder impuissant initialement
leur métier
je veux dire il ya quand même si quand
même je pense dans son discours sans de
dire oui qu'il y en a qui sont plus gros
que d'autres de base le tipi faire une
offre ces algues dans le bois no tsy
mais j'ai l'impression qu'après ça après
ça te comme lise les extrêmes qui depuis
peu pour moi c'est là un peu que le la
ligne sera situé hors de ton poids
naturel quand même c'est ça c'est
possible d'être hors de son pot naturel
qui s'épient
pile poils naturels du soin 10% de
génétique il faut pas non plus que ça
serve de
motion
rim fait que c'est pas mes habitudes de
vie qui ont trait comme étant quelqu'un
qui est ultra maïs le mouton qui a
développé des problèmes alimentaires à
cause qu à cause de la pression de la
société telequid puisqu'elle a elle le
fait qu'elle soit ultra mince et 10 mois
mais moi je suis le même genre j'ai un
métabolisme qui va vraiment vite c'est
comme je comprend peut-être que
génétiquement un métabolisme qui est
plus efficace que les autres mais
commenté la nature des bonnes même
naturellement genre lyon un problème
sous jacent à ce prix là je donne
l'exemple de quelqu'un qui est ultra
minces mais j'imagine que c'est la même
chose quelqu'un qui extrêmement grotti
fait que genre le sont 10 % de génétique
je le comprends absolument mais il faut
pas non plus que ça devienne
une jarre de béquilles qui t'empêche de
voir le problème sous-jacent du convoi
de ce jeudi mais de deux choses que je
veux dire à ce propos les c'est que oui
on a évolué et puis on reste liman fair
ils ont couru tout ce qui a changé
énormément par rapport à quelques
centaines d'années c'est notre
environnement je te veux nos jeunes
peuvent réagir cet environnement le
factice c est ce qu en ce moment à cause
que notre environnement changé il ya
certains jeunes qui s'expriment
différemment donc l on avait repris
cette personne on avait pris une
personne d'une centaine d'années qui
était justement un point on va dire
moyen puis on mettait dans
l'environnement aujourd'hui ce qui après
avoir un poids qui extrêmement en gros
ça serait posthume c'est le fait d'avoir
un environnement qui change et comme j
peut affecter l'expression de certains
gènes fait que ça peut effectivement
faire qui est bon on se rend compte que
oui et des personnes qui ont un poids
plus gros mais si cette personne mais
peut-être qu'on l'avait remis une
quelques centaines d'années que
l'environnement et échanges étaient qu'à
leurs épouses fois le jeu confort accès
je pense à garder en tête c'est parce
que c'est clair ben parce que là je
pense que le poids
face à quelqu'un qui mesure 6 et 5 il va
être plus lourd que moi tout le talent
de ses effectifs dont ça je comprends ce
que tu veux dire dans sa soute le
mais d'un point de vue individuel
ouais les
environnements va avoir un effet sur
l'expression de nos jeunes vraiment
comprendre et donc première aspects
l'autre aspect que je voulais qu'on
parle je m'en suis
mais je veux que je veux tu te retrouves
parce que parce que c'est super
intéressant
on parlait de t d extrême dit oui à ce
qui est souvent justement ne
l'impression qu'une personne va
peut-être dans un extrême on peut aller
vers l'extrême d'un gros star qui est de
donner l'argument génétique savane une
certaine complaisance de com mais je
suis comme de camoufler un
groupe ou une complaisance j'ai peu de
pouvoir la tuer ben on colle est une
certaine éducation à faire c'est ces
pipes moi pourquoi je mentionne cette
information le de la génétique c'est
pour déculpabiliser les gens parce
qu'encore une fois les pointes du peuple
entre intégraux et comment ce toi t'es
gros il y en a et de génétique qui
income quand même assez important ma
précieuse s'est posé un message de la
génétique on s'en fout il ya quand même
d'autres facteurs qui peuvent avoir un
effet sur le post lesquels on contrôle
peuvent vraiment non plus tu es jeux
dans notre âge notre contrôle papier
noter qu'il ya des choses comme ça qu'on
contrôle peu mais je pensais pour
déculpabiliser les 1 pierre précieuse je
pense pas que ça avait un argument que
je connais peu de gens quitter cet
argument important passé sur mon corps
pieds je peux pas le changer ben en fait
tu
je prends l'exemple de
personnes ultra minces pour
changer la direction l'agent du focus la
conversation parce que c'est moi c'est
ça c'est pas une question de gruppo
l'espresso
images et j'ai connu bien des gens qui
étaient
maladivement
qui disaient qu'ils étaient comme ça
mais que chez qu' il y avait une
alimentation misérable de genre
de cheetos par jour puis que c'est c'est
pas ton ne s'est pas ton ta génétique
qui fait seul c'est vraiment juste que
cache derrière le fait que cet âge
génétique mais c'était habitudes de vie
qui sont merdiques tipi tu veux pas tu
veux pas les parties faire faut il faire
face tu puis j'ai l'impression qu'ils
montrent que
moi j'ai beaucoup d'exemples de ce dans
cette direction là dessus c'est plutôt
un trouble alimentaire à ce moment est
peut-être qu'on prévoir les extrêmes
justement comme une façon que le poète
est manipulée mais avec un trouble
alimentaire c'est qu'on veut voir les
traits - justement ton nom c'est ma
génétique ben il va avoir un trouble
alimentaire qui est sous jacent c'est
surtout de la manière que tu me le
présente l'autre extrême ça peut être
aussi je peux te retrouver le menteur
aussi de
ccum hyperphagie boulimique je peux
c'est peut-être vous connaissent alors
mais c'est le trouble alimentaire qui
est le plus présent c'est des
compulsions alimentaires et donc on a
appris ce que comme des bines je mets
donc de manger rapidement des grandes
quantités nourriture puis un peu de
compensation après donc peu de
vomissements a que deux il ya peu de
laxatifs rien d'autre qu' prix mais ça
peut oui ça avoir un effet sur le poète
dont le remarqué ça peut effectivement
nous sortir de notre peau naturelle
comme tu dis de l'auto d'une fac oui
c'est sûr qu'en réglant le trouble
allemand table il pourrait avoir un
retour vers un port naturel
peut-être que non non plus le mais oui
les extrêmes tap est souvent plus lié à
des troubles alimentaires même avant un
trouble alimentaire puis
d'apparence
standard puis moi cette personne ne
semble en réalité d'une personne grosses
pattes anorexique ou s'ils crient mort
c'est fascinant c'est fascinant c'est ce
que je pense que tu
lis des tipis le ca on ne t on eu
beaucoup d'effet de mode alimentaire
d'argumentation métier de coach au
crédit des dépôts je pense que le but ce
qu'on voulait la base était d'amener
juste une petite nuance d'un genre de
discours j'ai l'impression qu'ils rendu
un discours dominant de comme un linge
etc
ben je sais pas s'ils dominent hamas
cueillis dans intrigue dans mon salon je
vois un
ruisseau sources auxquelles est exposée
mois mais on essaie je vais parler l
alimentation steve kean et réseaux se
sont entre autres il ya des gens qui la
maîtrisent pas fac dégelis a fait des
messages qui sont super confus mais ce
qui est tellement discours des diètes
que moi comme des sionistes j'ai
l'impression justement que je dois crier
mais message en gros y est pour essayer
justement d'essayer d'écraser un peu ce
qui est déjà pris dans cette forêt
confrontant ce qu'on va justement sur
les réseaux sociaux qui est des fois ça
manque de nuance et moi un poste a peut
être très long en faire le jeu change
les virgules puis des mots le parce que
je connais même pas si nuancé souffre on
pourrait me revenait pas ce qu'il faut
essayer d'avoir la preuve la plus
nuancée possible pour pas justement
déranger mais oui si si
en fait le feeling qui était de dire que
c'est comme une idéologie qui est qui
majoritaire si je pense que moi c'est ce
qu'elle épaule c'est juste que moi pour
le match qui s'est tellement dans la
société que je vois même plus les poches
de 10 athlètes et à la
méthodologie
de l'alimentation et du tri puis celle
que toi tu prônes je la vois pas ce que
je la remarque tout le temps dit mais si
je commence à remarquer autant les fois
où est ce que c'est et voici un
programme d'entraînement pour la perte
de poids voici tel diète pour faire
fondre les gros pépins chaque stored une
story sur deux c'est ça qu'est ce matin
dans le fond le fait que c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'on a l'impression que l'on
sait que le discours qui nous vaut kiki
comme challenger si je passe un peu où
est-ce qu'on est rendu t on aussi
justement tanneur cie bernard oui et bac
pendant trois ans et puis on lance une
deuxième fois avec catherine
informatique
tactile on a certains à quitter qu'on
arrive notre conversation le comme on
dit plutôt week end avec une base puis
en sachant que
les grands principes le des mille-îles
que justement le tilt et didier domi
rock minceur beenox toutes ces affaires
lui c'est de la cochonnerie mais c'est
que je pense qu on est passé d'un
extrême à l'autre puis je parlais juste
très personnellement moi je tenais
culture desdites le ya quelques années
du jeu et on a grandi là bas j'aime
exclu peu de ses discours et je pense
que jamais en crise on attend que sony
sur le projet urbain a
promis
j'ai participé comme des saignées salle
un culte sont des diètes bar confrontant
me fabriquer ce que j'ai fait a causé du
tort à des gens
bien comme profession de la protège le
meilleur pour mes clients plus j 10 juin
disait et j'ai peut-être causé du tort
le j'ai peut-être précipité des gens
dans une relation à cénac la nourriture
c'est super confrontent en fait c'est
moi même j'étais dans la culture dédié
depuis quand tu commences à apprendre un
peu l'alimentation du tiw mais moi je
t'avais dans un autre extrême
d'alimentation intuitive où justement
c'est un peu agressif
comment je voulais parler d'alimentation
du type achetés comme je peux pas
croquer des gens qui adorent encore
culture des diètes qui après sa main
s'il te ramener un peu dans les nuages
après six années dans les nuances puis
vu que c'est une approche qui on a parlé
tantôt qui vient quand même des années
90 mais qui chez sa mère un peu plus
populaire mais les gens justement un des
discours qui sont très peu nuancée qui
sont vraiment dans des extrêmes pas
recueilli commencent à s'approprier la
proche où ils sont juste consterné de
savoir qu'est ce que ça fait là sondés
disent qu'ils veulent stopper ça à tout
prix passer juste d'être emmené son un
prêt à des nuances de dire t'es pas cap
de vouloir perdre du poids je vais j'ai
voulu une bonne partie de ma vie perdue
pol ccc montée potable mais on fait quoi
et c'est une formation l'appui comment
est-ce qu'on peut t'aider à te sentir
mieux
merci infiniment des venu parler c'est
vraiment c'était vraiment une
conversation éclairante puis c'était
tout ce que je voulais que ce soit merci
à acheter du contenu excellent tu as
tout un podcast convient
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le bitume le pitch vous abonner pour
trop de leur part motrices ou trop de
long way trois pièces par morlaàs par
mois ils avaient les pattes carte en
avance acquise avec les premiers de
votre groupe d'amis à recruter les
podcasts qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir
avoir une avance quand vous allez tirer
la dynamique entre les amis tout le
temps avec une avance sur les jobs en
avance les entre deux toits mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que le
chèque le podcast su ni voulu nous
entendre jazz ou davantage on fait des
encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcasts etc là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on va en jaser on va
t'il et nicole non nicoli le maintenant
comme un fils travaille la place travot
de taza taille est là mais on jase on
parle de conversion qu'on m'aide à voir
mais ce si vous voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pétrole il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous